I promised a response tonight to what
we've been discussing throughout the
show the left killing free speech and
silencing contrary voices via
intimidation and sometimes slander our
founders warned about the dangers of
limiting speech Ben Franklin wrote
whoever would overthrow the liberty of a
nation must begin by subdue enough
rhiness of speech and yet here we are as
we've seen throughout the show from
diamond and silk to Professor McAdams
when individuals say things are
uncomfortable for the secular left
they aren't challenged or debated
they're branded demonized and sometimes
evicted altogether from the public
square that is not the American Way
we're winning the war of ideas on
immigration the economy life trade and
yes political correctness which is why
we're seeing the left-wing retaliatory
hit squads popping up everywhere today
in academia and Hollywood and in the
media the left will brook no dissent and
they will militantly police the borders
of their stale orthodoxy well we're not
going to stand for this so tonight I'm
announcing a new recurring series on the
Ingraham angle it's called defending the
first where we will expose the enemies
of the First Amendment a free expression
and free thought while showcasing those
brave voices making a difference so if
you've been subjected to threats or
intimidation because of your speech I
want to know about it
tweet meet me at ingram angle because
without free speech and a free
conscience were not truly a free people
we're not afraid to debate ideas here we
relish a vigorous debate they run from
it good luck with that